ah
[Música]
l juan es mi hermano no es que sus
hermanos sean menos pero qué lindo que
es nuevo
hoy vengo a hablar en su nombre y porque
nuestra vía es un constante desafío el
conformismo
me llamo isabel gonzález tengo 21 años y
tengo un blog donde escribo como es la
vida siendo hermana mayor de un niño
autista o mejor dicho con trastornos del
espectro autista o más sencillo lo que
será hermana de juan pablos
esto que les voy a decir a continuación
quizá les sorprenda las personas con
diagnósticos de lo que sea siguen siendo
personas parece muy sencillo cuando lo
escuchamos pero no saben lo difícil que
es entenderlo con la razón y con el
corazón
les voy a hacer otra revelación aprender
esto solo me lo dio la experiencia
la idea que la mayoría tenemos del
autismo es de acordarnos de aquella
película rain man la de dos hermanos el
raro que contaba cuánto fósforos se
caían en un segundo o que lo dejaban en
una sala de espera con una guía
telefónica y se aprendía los números y
direcciones de todo el pueblo
juan pablo es un autista no verbal de 10
años pero también es mi hermano no todos
los autistas son unos potenciales genios
como dice la gente pero si todos son
personas muchas veces nos dejamos perder
para llevarnos el perdón muchas veces
nos dejamos llevar para perdernos en la
teoría y por teoría me refiero a leer
los device que dice internet como keep
micro cautín
o que a temple grandín le apasionó la
ganadería y que capaz por ahí está la
solución y como somos seres que amamos
la atención
vamos a ir a nuestro facebook y poner
todo tipo de posteos en ponderados y
millones de perdón y millones de estos y
todo el murcia azul que encontremos
porque en teoría el azul representa el
mar profundo del autismo
pero voy a dejar de generalizar porque
en realidad esto fue lo que me pasó a mí
me convertí en lo que bauticé una
hermana superhéroes creí que juntos
íbamos a salir adelante siempre sentada
desde mi computadora y nunca enfocada él
estaba convencida de que acá la cura es
la estimulación sin siquiera hacer algún
esfuerzo por estimular
todo esto que hice no curó
milagrosamente a mi hermano no lo
estimuló no le funcionó como terapia
sólo sirvió para justificarme a mí
un invierno cuando habían pasado dos
años del diagnóstico me enferme y estuve
un mes encerrada en mi casa con mi madre
y mi hermano papá salía a trabajar pero
los demás estábamos todos adentro ese
mes por aburrimiento por compasión y
fundamentalmente por amor decidí
dedicarme a juan pablo decidí que no
importa si no habla nos podemos
comunicar igual aprendí a dar órdenes
cortas para expresar lo que quiero
decirle a buscarle la mirada cuando le
hablo y en vender todo tipo de cosas que
nunca hizo para que se termine matándose
de la risa
en algún momento se hizo el clic y me
encontré en el living de mi casa
bailando canciones infantiles o un
bailes inventados por mí
me di cuenta que tener un hermano no era
una cosa sino más y tener una hermana
autista - entonces aceptando que vamos a
convivir toda la vida me abrí
en estos años nos han pasado cosas
increíbles tanto buenas como malas
un día estaba discutiendo para ir a un
cumpleaños de 15 para venir acá en la
rural
y mi hermano se cayó con cuatro años a
un pozo con agua de dos metros de
profundidad
sorprendentemente dos años después
estábamos caminando por la calle felices
porque estaba pudiendo tolerar los
sonidos de los vehículos porque tienen
hipersensibilidad auditiva
también tiene hipersensibilidad
sensorial nosotros cuando nos vestimos
sentimos el contacto de la ropa con la
piel por un ratito después nos
acostumbramos que tenemos puesto el
sillín el blazer lo que sea él lo siente
durante todo el día entonces puede ser
pleno julio a ver - cinco grados llegar
a mi casa y ver a mi hermano corriendo
por el pasillo en pañales con la
comodidad de la poca ropa que tendría
cualquiera de nosotros en enero
pues un mes que fuimos a tomar un helado
y nos sentamos en una mesita en pleno 18
de julio como cualquier madre con sus
dos hijos esa bella mujer es mi mamá
me acompaña en mi primer vuelo de avión
y mientras que para él era su tercera
experiencia en el despegue yo estaba
muerta de miedo él estaba con los pies
para los post abrazos comiendo unos
snacks que les habían regalado las
azafatas
me encontré llegando a cansada después
de trabajar o estudiar y me recibieron
los besos y abrazos de mi hermano que en
estos años aprendió a darlos y saben que
es quizá el mejor estado en el que me he
encontrado
llegue alguna vez también triste e
incluso llorando y fue él el que se
sentó a mi lado acercarme las lágrimas
despacito con los dedos
me dio para consolarme me dio para
probarlas porque prueba con la boca
absolutamente todo lágrimas pasto
galletas
víboras mi pelo recién lavado
mamá tuvo que inventar el enfriado del
hielo que básicamente consta de ponerle
hielo a toda la comida caliente porque
detrás de la portería hay una pequeña
fiera esperando su segundo plato de
puchero
papá tuvo que inventar estás porterías
en la mitad del marco de la puerta ya
existente porque juan pablito se metía
en la cocina a cualquier momento del día
a sacar por ejemplo una milanesa
también hubo que poner una en mi cuarto
y se convirtió en el lugar donde
guardamos todas las cosas que
quisiéramos conservar entonces
desafiando al diseño en mi habitación
hay una cama escritorio ropero cuadros
material de cuando mamá ejercía de
maestra máquina de coser computadora
entre otras cosas
mucho cómo era la vida antes de juan en
realidad yo no sé por qué yo tenía 11
años cuando nació y 13 casi 14 cuando le
hicieron el diagnóstico lo que sí sé es
que yo no hago ni si así nomás las cosas
que la mayoría de ustedes sí
hace unos años nos jugamos acá a la
vuelta a las afueras de durazno porque
el patio nos creó el chiquito para un
niño que también tiene asociada a la
hiperactividad
cuando yo lo hice o me levantaba 6 y 10
de la mañana y llegaba a casa de las 14
mi casa tiene rutinas muy severas porque
los autistas necesitan de ellas para
vivir
ningún día del año después de las 21
puedo hacer ruido alguno aunque no le
digan a mamá pero siempre
y recibir llamadas enviar audios de
whatsapp
se imaginarán que escuchar música o
mirar la tele con sonido porque es la
hora de dormir y el mínimo ruido va a
dejar a mi hermano despierto toda la
noche como si fueran las doce del
mediodía
me di cuenta que tenía que ayudar a la
gente
perdón de adelante
vivir con un autista te genera la
necesidad de tener paciencia mucha mucha
paciencia porque si lo llevamos a la
informática
estamos configurados diferentes
por ejemplo cuando voy a festejar mi
cumpleaños tengo que salir a comer
afuera o irme de viaje porque se
imaginarán que muchas personas hablando
en simultáneo en tonos de voz muy alto
va a desatar una crisis pero no me
molesta porque los que son padres o
conocen a alguien que sea padre sabrá
que por los hijos se dejan de lado un
montón de cosas y se posterga en un
millón de otras pero que esas cosas se
hacen por amor
organizándonos mejor armando una rutina
o prácticamente un operativo
hace un año me recibí de visitadora
médica estudio inglés salgo de noche voy
a voy a conciertos y hago todo lo que
haría cualquier persona de mi edad o más
porque también tuve mi propio
emprendimiento donde cosía diseñaba y
vendía bolsos sobres y carteras en mi
propia casa y con mi hermano allí
adentro
como les decía juan pablo y yo somos
como dos tipos de software diferentes
uno es como android el software de
samsung y el otro es como yo es el de
apple
tenemos lo mismo sólo que de uno se hace
de una manera y el otro de otro
su tipo de razonamiento en algunas
situaciones es completamente inesperado
por ejemplo el ser literal
si está atravesado en una puerta y yo le
digo no te vayas a mover cualquiera de
nosotros diría ay sí perdón y se mueve
el seguramente no porque no entiende el
doble sentido
esto es algo que todos los autistas
tienes y si nosotros que lo sabemos no
nos ponemos a enseñarles a ustedes que
no tienen por qué nacer sabiéndolo
siempre vamos a dejar del lado de los
raros porque no se comportan como
nuestros padres
tampoco tienen maldad ellos no saben lo
que es hacerle mal al otro si no les voy
a mentir nos hemos pegado alguna vez o
nos hemos chocado pero no no es
intencional si le decís que este es este
movimiento que está haciendo sobre tu
pierna duele lo voy a dejar de hacer con
una sonrisa una sonrisa que siempre van
a ver reflejada en el rostro de mi
hermano juan pabló porque él es
inmensamente feliz
me di cuenta que tenía que ayudar a la
gente a refutar las millones de teorías
cerradas que manejan
por dos años busque la manera y en julio
encontré la solución empezar a contarla
desde el amor
después de 10 años de practicar el amor
hacia mi hermano más allá de su
diagnóstico de ayudar a las personas que
se me acercan con interés a hacerme
preguntas y principalmente con la
madurez de estar empezando mi vida
adulta me di cuenta que ningún
profesional iba a contar sin palabras
científicas la vida misma de un autista
si no es su propia hermana mayor
efectivamente
efectivamente concrete el blog y así lo
examen una hermana mayor
esto que les voy a decir es un mensaje
que me dio dio otra hermana mayor y no
estaba incluido en el speech pero es mi
pequeño homenaje a ella ella me decía
que nosotros somos la voces de sus
hermanos en algunos momentos como soy yo
y yo parada en frente a todos ustedes
pero en otros momentos son ellos los que
nos llevan a nuevas formas de
comunicarnos
si no fuera por el blog hoy mucha gente
no se estaría informando
la idea de este blog no hay generar mi
fama a levantarme la autoestima ni nada
que se le parezca la idea de este blog
es para sacar los prejuicios que tienen
ustedes que tuvieron mis padres y que
tuve yo antes de juan pablo
los cds se dicen que cada 59 personas
uno es autista se estima que en
argentina cada 11 minutos hay uno nuevo
diagnosticado y en uruguay no hay un
censo exacto pero se estima que hay unas
35.000 personas con el diagnóstico y
otras tanto así en él ya no es como
antes que lo sabían y nadie lo sabía que
estaban ahí y que pasaban por cualquier
cosa menos por lo que son
te vas a encontrar con alguno en la vida
con más de uno seguramente porque son
como todos ustedes capaces de grandes
cosas hay autistas estudiando en
secundaria haciendo carreras en la
universidad trabajando y haciendo todo
lo que un neurótico debe hacer en su
vida
pero quizá alguna de sus actitudes te
llamen más la atención te pongan
incómodo te molesten quizá no los
entiendas
pero lo que te quiero pedir es que mires
a esa persona y la trates con la misma
actitud que lo trataría si él o ella
fuera tu hermano menor
[Aplausos]
ah